If there is a feeling that you are in the center of the world, this must be it.
People visit from far away just to look up the buildings,...
...gaze at the stores and stroll down the famous avenues.
While many think of this place as a landmark,...
...you can't forget that it is also one of Manhattan's most important neighborhoods.
The vibe around here: think of the world's epicenter.
Even the traffic police want in on the glamour.
And that's the reason people actually live here.
From billionaires to middle-class professionals in comfortable high-rises.
From Fifth Avenue to Madison, it's all about finance, media, and retail.
I wonder what it must feel like to live in the center of the universe.